I met you Jackie Chan fan one of the  scenes he had just filmed was actually  in a Syrian town that had been flattened  by an Assad bombing oh some Fury among  activists dude they need to just get mad  at the locations are not him  people who understand departments who's  gonna get mad at the location scout  though wait they're mad because this is  a recent bombing and they filmed there  so it probably looks really funny when  they're screen testing and they're like  go in front of that rubble and say I  don't want no trouble  I don't want to travel do you think him  filming at this place was controversial  in his brain at all no he don't want no  trouble or the production not because  his son got caught smoking weed it then  China was like I'm a [ __ ] I'm gonna  [ __ ] you up if you don't [ __ ] turn it  around and he's like I I don't want no  trouble  [Laughter]